ARE IN CHARGE OF PROTECTING THE
PEOPLE YOU LOVE, NO MATTER WHAT
THEY TELL YOU ON TV.
YOU MAY HAVE COMPLETELY
FORGOTTEN IN THE FRENZY OF THE
PAST WEEK BUT THERE IS A
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL RACE
STILL ONGOING AND EVEN A DEBATE
LAST NIGHT, BUT THANKS TO
CORONAVIRUS, THERE WAS NO CROWD
TO PLAY TO YOU BY JOE BIDEN
STILL DID PLENTY OF PANDERING.
BIDEN VOWED TO ATONE FOR HAVING
THE WRONG SKIN COLOR BY HIRING
THOSE TRAITS RATHER THAN MERIT.
HE WILL LET THE WAY SOMEONE
LOOKS DECIDE WHO HE PICKS FOR
VICE PRESIDENT AND THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> I AM COMMITTED AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPOINT SOMEONE
TO THE COURTS, I WILL APPOINT
THE FIRST BLACK WOMAN TO THE
COURTS.
MY CABINET, MY ADMINISTRATION
WILL LOOK LIKE THE COUNTRY AND I
COMMIT THAT I WILL IN FACT
APPOINT A WOMAN TO BE
VICE PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: DOESN’T MATTER WHO
THE PERSON IS OR WHAT THE PERSON
BELIEVES HE HAS DONE IN LIFE,
GOING TO PICK SOMEONE WHO LOOKS
LIKE THIS.
THAT IS NOT PATRONIZING OR
ANYTHING.
DIDN’T STOP THERE THOUGH, HE
ALSO PROMISED IN HIS FIRST THREE
MONTHS AS PRESIDENT, NO ONE WILL
BE DEPORTED FROM THIS COUNTRY,
NOT EVEN VIOLENT CRIMINALS.
WATCH THIS.
>> "THE FIRST 100 DAYS" OF MY
ADMINISTRATION, NO ONE WILL BE
DEPORTED AT ALL.
FROM THAT POINT ON, THE ONLY
DEPORTATIONS THAT WILL TAKE
PLACE ARE COMMISSIONS OF
FELONIES IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
>> SO TO BE CLEAR, ONLY FELONS
GET DEPORTED AND EVERYONE ELSE
IS SAFE.
>> ASKED.
>> Tucker: WITH TIME RUNNING
OUT FOR HIS PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN, BERNIE SANDERS DID
NOTHING SIGNIFICANT TO TEAR DOWN
BIDEN BECAUSE HE DOESN’T
ACTUALLY WANT TO WIN, HE JUST
MUST’VE JUMP AROUND AND PLAY
REVOLUTIONARY.
WHY DOESN’T HE JUST SAY THAT?
ALMOST SABOTAGED HIMSELF ANYWAY
WHEN HE MISTAKENLY USED 2,005
ERA DEMOCRATIC LINGO WHICH IS
NOW BANNED BECAUSE IT’S RACIST,
WATCH.
>> ANYONE WHO SHOWS UP TO BE
TESTED FOR CORONAVIRUS GETS
CORONAVIRUS TREATED WOULD BE
HELD HARMLESS.
THEY WERE CERTAIN THINGS CANNOT
DEPORT AN UNDOCUMENTED ALIEN
FOR -- UNDOCUMENTED PERSON FOR
AND THAT WOULD BE ONE OF THEM.
>> Tucker: NOTICED THE
QUESTION AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
SCREEN.
HOW CAN WE MAKE ILLEGAL ALIENS
FEEL SAFE ENOUGH TO GET TESTED
FOR CORONAVIRUS?
THAT IS THE NUMBER ONE CONCERN
ON CNN.
HE NEARLY BLEW IT RIGHT THEREBY
USING THE WRONG PHRASE.
MARK STEYN WATCHED LAST NIGHT’S
DEBATE AND HE JOINS US NOW.
HOW DO YOU ASSESS THIS, MARK?
>> I THINK IT’S TERRIBLE, THIS
IS WHAT IT’S LIKE.
IT’S DIFFERENT IF YOU ARE ONE OF
THE YOUNGER CANDIDATES, IF YOU
ARE LIKE THAT SKATEBOARDING GUY
OR IF YOU ARE LIKE PETE FROM
SOUTH BEND.
YOU DON’T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
WORD ALIEN IS.
YOU DON’T KNOW WHAT IT MEANS BUT
THEY’VE LEFT THEMSELVES WITH
FINDING IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
WALK ON THESE EGG SHELLS SO THEY
NATURALLY DEFAULT TO OLD-TIME
WORDS WHICH YOU ONLY HERE IN THE
RECREATIONAL LANGUAGE OF THE
SENIORS HOME LIKE ALIEN.
THIS IS THE SAME GUY WHO IS
TELLING US THAT TRUMP WAS
XENOPHOBIC FOR USING WORDS
FOREIGN VIRUS.
A VIRUS CAN BEGIN ALIEN, A
PERSON CAN’T BEGIN ALIEN.
ALIEN.
JOE BIDEN COMPLETELY LOST IT IS
ATTACKING US FROM ABROAD AND BY
THAT VERY PHRASE, KIND OF
IMPLYING THAT THE VIRUS IS SORT
OF FULL REIN SOME WAY.
HE IS IN DANGER OF DEFAULTING TO
SANITY.
WHICH IS ALWAYS THE PROBLEM WHEN
YOU’VE GOT PEOPLE WHO ARE OLD
ENOUGH TO REMEMBER BEFORE THE
LINGO HAD BEEN CORRUPTED.
>> Tucker: WHEN THEY REMEMBER
REALITY, YOU ARE TOTALLY RIGHT.
SO DID BERNIE SANDERS MAKE ANY
HEADWAY WHATSOEVER LAST NIGHT?
>> NO, HE DIDN’T AT ALL.
HE THREATENED TO YOU.
WHAT’S ABOUT THIS WHOLE DEBATE
TO GO BACK TO MAYOR PETE AND YOU
SEE THEM, IT’S LIKE WATCHING
IDEOLOGICAL COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
IT’S RATHER SWEET WHEN YOU ARE
22, 32, 47, 58.
WHEN YOU’VE GOT TWO GUYS PUSHING
80 HAD NOTHING THEY ARE SAYING
IS ACTUALLY RELEVANT TO THE
SITUATION, THE CHALLENGES FACING
THE COUNTRY.
IS KIND OF PATHETIC.
WE WASTE SO MUCH TIME -- I SAID
AGES AGO ON THIS SHOW, WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT TRANSGENDER
BATHROOMS, THE DEMOCRATS WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT WHETHER THEY
SHOULD HAVE A TRANSGENDER
VICE PRESIDENT WHEN THE ZOMBIE
APOCALYPSE IS FINALLY UNLEASHED
AND BREAKS INTO THE DEBATE THEN
DEVOURS THEM ALL.
THIS IS A COMPLETE WASTE OF
TIME.
UTTERLY IRRELEVANT, STALE
WORLDVIEW OF GLOBALISM.
>> Tucker: THAT’S EXACTLY
RIGHT, BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS
THEY’LL FEEL GOOD ABOUT
THEMSELVES AS THEY DO IT.